This is pretty fascinating.
As I've said, tap-taps are how
everybody gets around in Haiti,
these beautifully colored painted buses
and they're painted by artists with icons.
This is Anthony, Thony,
and you're from Haiti.
Yeah, I'm from Haiti.
Nice to meet you.
And are you an artist?
Yeah, I'm an artist, I'm a visual artist.
Tell me what you've done.
At 1:00 in the morning,
my girlfriend just broke up with me.
I was crying at night and I was like,
it's either I go out or I
stay home to do what I love
and then I decided to
make the illustration.
Oh my god, this is fantastic.
Look at this.
You've captured me.
Kind of sweaty and nervous.
This is really nice.
I would love to see this on a tap-tap.
That would be great.
It's possible.
That would be, we're
gonna make this happen.
That would be great.
I have to because I'm up there with,
you think about it,
there's Rihanna, there's Lionel Messi,
Yeah, Jesus.
Jesus.
And then Conan.
That's usually the four,
if you think of it.
Right?
Yeah.
So this all happened because you broke up.
Your girlfriend broke up with you?
Yeah.
Once it gets out that you've done this,
you're gonna have many options.
Okay?
(laughs)
You are my personal portrait artist
here in Haiti.
Thank you.
That's an official position.
Nice!
And with it
comes great power and lots of ladies.
Responsibilities?
No, no, no.
With great power comes lots of ladies.
That's what Spiderman says.
No Spiderman's lying.
Oh you did?
Yeah I'm a comic book artist.
A Haitian superhero?
Yeah.
Terrific, tell me about him.
What's his name?
Djatawo.
Djatawo, I love that!
What's his superpower?
He can teleport himself
and he can also use his energy--
If he can teleport himself is that because
there's so much traffic in Port-au-Prince?
That's true!
That's why you came up
with the idea, right?
Yeah, yeah!
Can I say Djatawo's greatest power?
He can turn a break-up with a girlfriend
into something positive.
That's Djatawo's power.
You are amazing.
Put this on your local tap-tap.
Anthony before you go,
I want to present you with something.
We are Team Coco and I want you to have
a Team Coco shirt.
Oh this is so cool.
Now there's one problem.
What is it?
I found out that Coco has meaning
(laughing)
in Haiti that we didn't
know anything about.
We found out here that Coco means,
and you can say it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's it say?
Vagina.
Don't be scared.
(laughing)
See that's part of the reason
you guys broke up.
You were afraid.
(laughing)
Vagina.
I wanted to thank Nadesh Delfourt.
She's the one who brought me here.
Where is she?
What is your name?
Nadesh.
You are gorgeous.
You're beautiful.
Thank you.
How long have you two known each other?
Long time.
Like almost 20 years, something?
Yeah.
Wow.
And now he's single.
Are you single?
No, I'm not single.
Unfortunately, I'm not.
(laughing)
That could change?
Nothing, nothing.
Because he is now Team Coco,
we looked up the word for the male part.
(laughing)
You can be Team Zozo.
So anyway.
We're gonna sell a lot of these in Haiti.
Always a man of my word,
I commissioned Anthony
to execute his vision.
And within 24 hours I was immortalized
on Haitian public transport.
To check out Thony's artwork,
including his Haitian superhero,
go to djatawo.com.